[Music]
being your first lady has been the
greatest honor of my life and I hope I
made you proud Michelle Obama fights
back tears as she delivers her final
speech as first lady and as I in my time
in the White House I can think of no
better message to send to our young
people and my last official remarks this
first lady so for all the young people
in this room and those who are watching
know that this country belongs to you
Obama's farewell took place at the 2017
school counselor of the year event at
the White House FLOTUS took the moment
to thank all those who made the reach
higher initiative a success now when we
first came up with this idea we had one
clear goal in mind we wanted to make
higher education cool the first lady
closed with a hopeful message to the
youth of America I want our young people
to know that they matter that they
belong so don't be afraid you hear me
young people don't be afraid be focused
be determined be hopeful be empowered
[Music]
you